i a mãe de dez mil anos atrás
o homem quando começou na agricultura
começou a praticar a agricultura começou
a cib nação e com isso veio a viagem
imigração em kolomen da ação a coligação
de novas terras ovos e compactar do
século essa colonização teoricamente
diminuiu até chegar ao ponto zero será
os surdos em dação colonizados mão b
o vídeo mundo sonoro visual você terá o
barulho do trovão na chuva
será que tem água na cachoeira água do
rio
será que tem ponto interrogação água dos
mares encontrando com as pedras de crack
benson um cantor cantando ou será que
tem cantão tem letra e é fantástico
sapateado draghi benson que tem um
alguma coisa
coreografia ritmo
o rugido do leão ou numa topete que faz
parte do passado eo cantor e no brasil
será que tem som são a imagem que passa
todo dia na televisão o que o surdo b na
televisão isso é isso imagem e seu
recurso do surdo imagem imagem desenhos
o recurso do surdo é a imagem do
pensamento
a estrutura da língua de sinais é
através da imagem
pergunto novamente ea música pra que ela
tem o mesmo efeito
a música é incrível a moça que ela
transmite pra você e as pessoas pra nós
nós ouvimos a música e começamos a
sentir a emoção e começamos a chorar
comentou amanda mexer o corpo
dançar e começaram a passear mas será
que ela traduzido pelas mão tem o mesmo
e pinto para o surdo quando visualiza
uma pessoa um tempo ele me ensina
entrando cindo a música terá que ela
tenha a mesma emoção que transmite para
pessoa que ouve girar a chave na porta
da casa a campainha pin da campainha a
descarga pode xixi e cocô em da cena que
tem som o mundo sonoro a educação o
professor quando paula o da 'boa a
entonação um sorrido oxi
ouro de uma criança
e quantos quanto som é o dia a dia
fazer amor o sussurro a chuva no telhado
o som de um estridente de um garoto
passando na panela violão instrumentos
musicais que têm grande ma valor
inestimável para as pessoas que são
músicos e estudantes de música que
curtem a música um grande valor para
pessoas surdas será que bem esse valor
porque que a educação até hoje querem
que a pessoa surda aprendam o mundo
aprendam uns conhecimento através do
recurso sonoro porque ainda tem mão
mostrar e ensinar matemática ensinar
português de ensinar todas as
disciplinas de de pré a pé
a graduação pós mestrado doutorado todo
com recurso sonoro é acessível para
pessoas urna à pessoa surda com a afp
parem parem
não é isso que funciona não é isso não é
tem que ser mundo é muita mulher som e
som e som
o mundo é tudo e som tudo que convida
orelha a orelha a orelha onemi a aí o
estudo para tentar matar a pessoa que
apresente sintomas o vasco tá aí a
pessoa surda anda está com uma pessoa
que houve a habitual o papa para aí
parei porque escuta escuta aí você não
escuta começa a falar alto oi a pessoa
surda oi oi
aí técnico tô te surdo aimar teve de
cortar um pouquinho o professor dentro
da sala de aula
nós temos um aluno tudo sentado aqui na
sala de aula ou estuda lá protestou
então não está bom agora que eu vou
escrever aqui na luta muito aquela
cultura até lá quando aquele que
aprendeu a leitura labial piscina do
suporte labial e ficar olhando para
todos os colegas todos os colegas que
olhando o cabelo resposta do professor
falando e escrevendo falando e
escrevendo falando em um tremendo
olha é nós vamos cantar agora uma música
aquarela qualquer outra música tudo tá
lá ciranda cirandinha é tudo pela
escravos de jó jogava ocasionar tudo
está lá lá
é isso que a inclusão preto dudu
aí o que é o som eu vou passar novamente
o vídeo para vocês sentirem o som
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o u1 el mar em desistir ensinam surdo a
também do som do recurso sonoro deve
mostrar o recurso sonoro através da
imagem
eu amo abraçar o meu liquidificador
sabe por quê porque eu sou surda e perda
bilateral profunda tem memória auditiva
eu posso dizer isso parem de colonizar o
surdos
obrigado
[Aplausos]